[Musique]
j'espère que mon doigt pendant ces
michel serrault et de jean poiret vous
êtes des stars internationales ont péri
à bord à bord ni connu pire il ya
longtemps que les cadors de cette pièce
mais suivra c'est la création c'est tout
de suite après la guerre de 14 si on
fait un avilissement quelques années
quand vous avez joué les premiers mois
cette pièce comment comment avez vous
fait pour garder votre sérieuses mais on
ne me regardez pas ben c'est d'ailleurs
en ont répliqué non seulement par des
par des éclats de rire mais personnel
même et par des répliques aussi qui
s'enchaînaient parce que faut pas
oublier que c'est une des pièces il ya
parsifal et la cage aux folles qui font
des résistances comme ça ce donc
parsifal était dirigée par toscanini où
furent brengues l'air ça faisait 1h15 de
différence la cage aux folles comme ça
ça faisait des écarts d'une heure qui
permettait aux gens de revenir deux fois
parce qu'il s'est pendu dans une pièce
photos de préciser que la cage aux
folles continuent
oui oui ces quotidiens jusqu'à petit don
faut bien à donner du lait à nos enfants
comme ripoux qui est quand même bon êtes
vous déjà allé aux états unis pour vous
rendre compte du succès du film bat
michel mais écoutez on en parle mais mon
nom je n'ai pas eu la curiosité un coup
tous les américains les indices
américains qui viennent sur ses plateaux
nous parle du succès du film et vous
vous n'êtes pas capable de parler d'un
succès gros cri est ce que vous
envisagez maintenant de vous expatrier
si vous propose maintenant le berin pour
le berry toujours jean et michel vous
avez fait beaucoup de choses ensemble
dans notre vie est ce que vous allez
chanter vous ne savez pas tout oui je ne
sais pas tout mais grâce à ce que vous
avez chanté sur une grande et il est
tard il vous est arrivé de chanter
ensemble
non non on fredonne mon changement parce
que c'est une audition à bayreuth
non parce que vous avez semé d'honneur
et on n'aurait pas garde dans une
émission à télévision un grand standard
j'ai passé un grand standard du berry ou
un grand standard américain mais c'était
un petit peu bref vous souvenez pas
couanau père était vétérinaire mais je
ne chante plus depuis le nord si julien
julie julien ne connais pas agnelet mon
père lui vous puissiez aller dire mais
c'est la mélodie connais pas la wii
serait bien passé c'est une grande
première au et non c'est pas film est en
train d'écouter ya pas lui c'est
tellement mira banquettes à bulles et
julien ont prévu des plus riches terres
rostropovitch ya pas eu sabia poste
[Rires]
journée m'a fait penser à faire il quoi
ça fait un succès à la création ça à la
création oui oui oui mais elle n'a pas
été ça n'a pas été vraiment repris en
scène
non non ce après est ce qu'on appelle un
tube on engage aujourd'hui et ça n'a pas
été c'est est un peu en avance sur son
époque ça n'a pas été compris tout de
suite
à l'époque c'était c'était gounod
sociétés d'aviron les grands mélodistes
traditionnelle et c'était très très
avancé - dans le texte aussi nous
intéresser ses terrines et ça vous une
fois je vais vous rendre votre
instrument parce que sa formule parce
qu'on va tout même essayé de parler
sérieusement car votre acte de toujours
essayer au sergent c'est tout de même la
regarde
joyeuses pâques je me le faites tourner
parce que je suis petit
un petit hic majan joyeuses pâques oui
que vous jouez au palais royal
galfond maria pas qu entre au dépôt de
la distribution j'ai en moi justement
sans vous sans vous on peut en dire deux
mots car vous allez nous abandonner dans
quelques instants pour rejoindre aux
petits camarades là bas et oui faut
quand même génial mais les motards sont
la plaie motards soient si on peu près
six ans de mode qu ici ça se passe bien
sûr sur un sur la longueur d'un week-end
de pâques
oui et c'est une histoire braves
c'est un monsieur c'est un monsieur qui
a des gens injustes à monsieur qui a à
une cinquantaine d'années enfin
j'anticipe un peu parce que murray que
38 ans ouaddou comme on le sait est à
une cinquantaine
ne riez pas encore on fait beau c'est
beau julien de rire comme ça deux rues
de vote aux aînés tu croyais que des 37
kerbala
et alors ce monsieur veut encore se
prouver des choses en dragon un peu la
mine est comme on dit dans les milieux
intellectuels et et alors il ira bien
effectivement une mine est chez lui et
puis la femme la femme débarque et
seulement 7
cette dame bon ça n'a rien
d'extraordinaire jusqu'à présent ça
arrive dans tous les bons foyers
répertoriés mais malheureusement la
femme arrive il est obligé de faire
passer cet
cette minette pour sa fille pour ce fils
qu'il aurait eu d'un premier mariage
voilà et la femme tony magi de la suite
et c'est ça son drame
on imaginait ce que je vais lui poser
une question à jouer le fondeur des
fêtes de pâques que ça marche aussi bien
à mes relations normales non pas que j
attends tu n'as pas vu les mains parce
que ça va s'appeler joyeuse bande quotas
[Musique]